all right my name is Sully I'm a
software engineer at Google here at Q
con Seattle and now I'm here with Tim
Hawkins the granddaddy of kubernetes he
does not need an introduction but for
those of you who don't know him he's
been involved with the project from the
very beginning and he's helped architect
a lot of the kubernetes project so Tim
can you tell us a little bit about those
early days and how the project has
evolved since then sure you know the
early days it was really about bringing
out some of the ideas that we had in
board taking some of the lessons that we
had learned through Borg and bringing
them out to the rest of the world
we saw the docker thing happening and it
was pretty exciting but we knew where
that road would go and we knew that
something like borg would be needed so
we wanted to take sort of the best
lessons that we had learned through the
borg and omega process and share them
with the world I mean it was a lot of
fun to be able to do that and you know
from from then on the community has
grown at this amazing pace and we're
here standing among 8,000 of my best
friends
and it's a little overwhelming that it's
awesome so what are some of the
challenges that the community is facing
now as you said it's grown to a
tremendous scale there are more
contributors now than ever how are we
dealing with that and what are some of
the challenges that come with it we got
a bunch of challenges some of them are
you know how do we stay on track how do
we not lose focus of the core principles
of the project we need to make sure that
we don't try to do too much we sort of
stay within our swimlane but we want to
we want to be sure to empower other
communities other projects projects like
sto and Kay native are really
interesting to me
because they build on top of committees
you can see more and more effort in
communities going into extensibility and
mechanisms around that there's a bunch
of talks here at cube con about
extensibility so we're really leveraging
that to make sure the project stays at a
reasonable size the community
contributors now are dealing with issues
of compatibility and growth and scope
like every new change has a chance to
break every one of these users and so we
have to be more careful than we've ever
been
and
one of your talks this week was about CR
DS and that's one of the main mechanisms
for extensibility can we deep dive into
that a little bit and get technical what
are some of the challenges with CR DS
why are we why do they exist how should
people use them are they only for
external people are they part of the
core project what how does that work
thanks for the lead in this was my
lightning talk this week it was really
about the birth of CR DS custom resource
definitions this is our one of our
extensibility mechanisms and how that's
being used in kubernetes and it was one
of those things that was summarizing and
emergent you know it's one of these
things if you set out to do on purpose
you probably would fail at but because
it emerged organically from the project
it was really successful it's a way that
people are extending kubernetes to add
their own types their own concepts into
our API machinery it started off as a
thing for people to just prototype and
play with and it wasn't really very good
it was very second class but now it's
very much a first-class thing we've been
adding more more support for versioning
and schema and validation to the point
now that you can actually build real
things with it and I know you know this
because we made you and your cig be one
of our pioneers all right and you guys
thanks for falling on that grenade but
like some of the storage work is
happening as CR DS it's not just an
extension it's actually built in as part
of the system it's just a resource
definition that's not encode it's in
declaration so what does that mean for
the built-in types are there going to be
no more built-in types what does the
future look like well long term I would
like to see us with an empty API server
that's got nothing in it except
namespaces custom resource definitions
admission control web hooks and all the
stuff you need to run C RDS everything
else gets kicked out pods services
deployments all get moved out into
custom resource definitions and
kubernetes machinery becomes a separate
project and it's a thing that you load
type sets into and you go forward from
there
and so this kubernetes api machinery can
then be utilized by multiple project
it's not going to be kubernetes specific
it could be used by sto and other
projects as well absolutely I mean this
is already happening but today we're
managing it through several different
forks of the codebase so we have a
generic API server in an example
tenshun server and you know we shouldn't
need to do those things they should all
be on the same the same basis got it
let's talk about the community a little
bit the community of course has grown
tremendously in the last few years how
do we manage that what are some of the
challenges with a community of that
scale and I know you served on the
steering committee for a while can you
tell us what the steering committees
view on this as the community is what
makes this project successful like
unambiguously that is what makes it
unique in the world and we need to make
sure that we make that healthy for
people we have thousands tens of
thousands of contributors at this point
and honestly the weak spots that we have
I think are the same as a lot of other
projects it's things like documentation
and onboarding we're never going to be
quite good enough on that but we're
spending a lot of time and energy trying
to make those things better we've got a
whole sig that is just devoted to the
contributor experience and making things
better we had our contributor summit
yesterday where we had 400 ish
contributors and would be contributors
here 500 on the wait list yet and more
on the wait list they were here to talk
about how to contribute to kubernetes
what the state of the project is so I
think we need to make sure that we we
are doing things to make these people
successful they are the way that we were
able to grow sort of at the rocket ship
growth that we've been having and what
are some of those projects that we're
doing to help continue to sustain that
growth I mean we've got everything from
better documentation and onboarding we
had a new contributor track at the
contributor summit so this is for people
who are just starting out with
kubernetes to come and learn how does
our codebase work how does our how do
our bots all of the github workflow that
we've built how do those things work
we've also got people who are building
those bots we've got a group of people
we call inch prod at Google and they're
building these things like robots that
make interacting with github a little
smoother a little easier and scaling up
a little bit better just among things
we've also got all the documentation
people which is serving purposes both
for end users and for new contributors
in terms of leadership in the community
what I've noticed as I talked to ash and
Janet and other folks is that this
community really kind of incubates new
leaders is that natural is that
that was intended and how does that
happen and what are your thoughts on
that
I take it as a real compliment actually
it's very intentional
we know that projects only survive as
long as their leadership survives and I
know that I won't be here forever I want
this project to be around a long time so
I want to make sure that there's people
who know what they're doing who have
some real battle scars who know where
the bodies are buried who are coming up
through the ranks to to take over the
project I think this is a really
important part of the way the steering
committee is set up you know we set it
up in a way that all the people who
originated the project only a few of us
can possibly be on steering committee
after the end of this year and it's I
think it's really important so we've got
fresh fresh blood coming in fresh eyes
fresh perspectives awesome so let's
switch gears a little bit and talk about
UConn this is probably your what sixth
coupon worldwide yeah yeah so can you
talk about what changes you've seen and
what you're looking forward to this week
well the first cube con was four hundred
and something people so we're roughly
twenty times bigger than that this time
so it's a little bit of a different
thing but at the same time I you know I
walk around the show floor here and I'm
constantly seeing people that I know
people I've worked with on the project X
Googlers people I've worked with at
other companies friends of friends it's
amazing right it really is like hanging
out with 8000 of my best buddies went to
the the party last night there was a
reception last night
and I just hung out with people and just
talked and sometimes we talked about
good Randy's and sometimes we talked
about other stuff and it was it's really
awesome it's a little overwhelming
honestly the keynote room is is pretty
massive but it's amazing that these
people are all here to talk about this
thing that is making hopefully their
lives a little bit better yeah that's
awesome
last question put you on the spot what
is your favorite cue con memory my
favorite Kubik on memory boy
probably the first cube con at this
hotel in San Francisco where it was
amazing to see 400 people here to talk
about this thing and they were all early
adopters the people who had actually
been using the system and playing with
it I knew almost everybody and Brian
Clayton and I sequestered ourselves in a
backroom and put up on the white board
out in the lobby come to room whatever
and get your PR shot down to person and
we had a line of people who are there to
get their PRS live reviewed nice we can
try that again and see how long all
right thank you very much to him and
thanks for talking to you take care
[Music]